no one has claimed responsibility for a
global cyber attack that disabled at
least 2,000 computers in the United
States and Europe the attack started
yesterday in Europe it's still spreading
this morning hackers crippled computers
and total users to pay a $300 ransom to
restore access Ukraine reported the most
attacks through its power grid
government offices banks and grocery
stores were all affected the cyber
attack impacted server u.s. companies
including the drug maker Merck and food
companies Mondelez international and
Nabisco it also affected a Pennsylvania
healthcare system
CBS News senior national security
analyst Brand Townsend was a homeland
security adviser for president george w
bush frank good morning how
sophisticated is this and therefore
where might it have come from well it's
one we're not sure where it came from of
course there's much speculation the
attack seemed to start in Ukraine and so
we we know that Russia has sort of been
behind some of these sorts of attacks
against Ukraine but I don't think
anybody really knows charlie the problem
with this is you recall the wanna cry
attack which also was a ransomware
attack
this takes that sort of to the next
level that was stopped because there was
a kill switch they haven't found a kill
switch to this one yet and this is more
once this is out in your system it sort
of propagates itself without direct
commands from the hackers and so it's it
is pervasive and it is sort of difficult
to deal with once it's been launched now
we keep hearing that this this hacking
attack was used by something that was
created by the NSA so what is it
responsibilities of the NSA to protect
us and how do we protect ourselves Gail
this is the real big debate now of
course NSA has not confirmed nobody in
the government has confirmed that this
comes from the eternal blue exploit that
it was an NSA tool but what we've seen
is wanna cry built on that exploit and
now this Pecha attack builds again and
that's the problem when you Koopman the
government creates an exploit and lets
it loose into the world whether
intentionally or not it then gets added
to and turned around like a boomerang
and comes back at you and Americans are
rightly saying wait a minute my tax
dollars help fund the development of
these tools don't you have an obligation
to protect me and the intelligence
community struggles they
these exploits to legally go out and use
them against foreign intelligence
targets but then what is their
obligation in terms of the American
people
well the companies pay the ransom well
you know it's interesting charlie this
is all these ransoms seem to come back
to the same Bitcoin address in other
words you've got to pay your $300 to the
same Bitcoin address I think individuals
certainly will and the question really
is your right to be asking is will the
companies I'll tell you if they lose
money every day they don't have access
to these hard drives and so you know
you're worried that they will which only
encourages these kinds of attacks and
this is the second major attack I guess
in the last month what are the
vulnerabilities here in the United
States you know the interesting thing is
once this became public right Microsoft
did what you would expect a responsible
company to do they put what we call
patches out there so these are patches
to cover the vulnerabilities in
Microsoft seven and ten which is what
the petya attack takes advantage of the
problem is in big organizations as you
know we have thousands of people does is
it properly installed and what we're
finding is some didn't install it at all
some some didn't install it completely
there you go Fran Townsend thank you so
much